meses después de la llegada al poder de
la junta militar en myanmar el 1 de
febrero el líder del gobierno de facto
anunció la puesta en libertad y retirada
de cargos contra miles de personas en el
país encarceladas a raíz de las
protestas contra el golpe de estado
por diferentes razones participaron en
protestas violentas en el mundo entre
los que han estado cumpliendo condenas o
se han enfrentado en juicio las personas
adecuadas recibirán un indulto y
mostrarán sus méritos durante el
festival the time you ever el anuncio
llega después de que la asociación de la
onu en el sudeste asiático decidiera
excluir a mi amar de la próxima cumbre
por la gestión de crisis en el país por
parte de la junta militar que califican
de insuficiente a elegir wong ho wing
las violaciones han sido continuas se
han registrado detenciones masivas y
éstas se han intensificado desde el 7 de
septiembre que es cuando el denominado
gobierno de unidad nacional declaró la
guerra a medicare world desde el golpe
de estado del 1 de febrero me amar ha
estado sumida en el caos con constantes
protestas y represión del ejecutivo
militar los enfrentamientos entre los
detractores del gobierno y los
manifestantes se han cobrado la vida de
más de 1100 personas y al menos siete
mil trescientos están en la cárcel
actualmente según la asociación de
asistencia a presos políticos